what I love about a question like this
is that it pulls together all kinds of
things that you've already learned but
it shows it to you in a kind of
unfamiliar way now I'm always certain
that once I show you the answer you'll
be like ah of course you'll all say oh I
could have done that
but the difference between whatever
better listen I'm about to show you and
whether you can do it yourself is a
little bit like how many of you've
watched MasterChef before okay thank you
hands down what I want to point out to
you is that I and this is what they
often have to do the show I can follow
recipes right like you like cooking a
meal I can follow recipes I'm really
good at following recipes okay and I'm
really glad if you're you'll like that
too but I'm no chef I'm no chef I have
no understanding of like what flavors
have put supposed to combine together
well if you get given a mystery box and
this is just random ingredients and then
you have to think of something that will
bring them all together why do you put
an oven at 180 degrees and not like 250
degrees I can tell you which one you
should do if you've got a recipe but I
don't know why I don't know why you add
cream of tartar I don't even know what
cream of tartar is but apparently it's
important right now when you look at
this question and you look at this
question I'm convinced if I've done my
job or here so you guys know everything
you need to know in this question but
you're not sure how to combine them okay
so first thing I'm gonna notice is look
at the question take a lot of time it
says what are h rectangles dimensions so
that's like how wide how high are each
of these rectangles right now I don't
know what those numbers are cuz two
numbers I'm trying to find and I don't
know what they are but lucky for me I
have a whole branch of maths that's all
about working with numbers when you
don't know what they are what's it
called its called algebra right so the
question never says use algebra
but I look at a lot haha this is a great
question where algebra can help me I
want to know the width I want to know
the height so I'm gonna use algebra I'm
gonna give each of those a name okay so
for example let's have a look down here
I've got A's and B's and C's I'm gonna
say well with I'll call that W maybe you
want to add onto your diagram that
you've drawn there
there's the width across this way of one
of the rectangles okay that's the width
I also got how tall the rectangle is how
high it is so I'm gonna call this thing
over here H for height okay so I've got
a width
I've got a high I don't know what they
are right but that's okay you can win
now the wonderful thing about giving
these names is now I can see where they
are right I've got them over there on
the bottom left but where else can you
see W and H where else are they yeah
turn on on the top right right next to
me there's another W this way and
there's another H this way right that's
good but remember you also know all
these rectangles are the same so there's
one more place or one more pair of spots
where you can see WH can you see them
they're a bit so helpful to kill okay
you can see this spot here right what's
that
that's eight right and this one here
this is W right it's the same one again
do you see it do you see it cuz the same
rectangle it's just been moved around
okay all right now almost there what was
there you know how I drew I drew those
blue lines they're kind of scaffolding
things that help you out right I said
that was my clue now whether you realize
it or not let me move this question out
of the way you actually all know how
long those lines are for instance this
one that goes all the way from the top
to the bottom you should all be able to
tell me how long that is
hmmm I think it's six now my question to
you is weight yeah you look at the other
one so six this is up and down right up
and down
I've got coordinates which coordinates
are up and down coordinates it's the
what we want and we give it their called
wise right which is the second value
it's a it's the four and the ten you see
that so I've got to go climb up from
four all the way up to ten and that's
six does that make sense okay I know the
the height what about this one across
this way well you can help me out with
this more right this is eight okay how
do I know eight where does it come from
eleven eleven take away three okay this
is good I'm almost there I was there
what's this okay if I look up and down
right up and down
I've got W plus h do you see that W plus
h and they're going to be that up and
down late right six you agree with that
what whatever W in HR okay what about
this width and how can I use that what
would you like me to write how far do I
have to go in terms of w's and H is to
go from the left all the way to the
right can you see it can you see look
you've got to go W this way right and
then you've got to do another W to get
all the way across do you see it so - W
- lots of W ears ah so - lots of W is
eight so one line of W is for now that
you know what W is what's H H is -
because you can put it into here do you
see that so what did I do
well let me start again what did we use
what knowledge did we use Brad to be
able to solve this question think you
all knew what to tell me to do what
knowledge did I use I use now algebra
think very much what else did I use
am i good numbers I had to use the how
did I know how wide and how high
yeah units coordinates you all know
these things but I combined it in a way
you didn't expect and you can do that
too
all right you cannot rule off that
diagram say yeah oh oh so so I bet into
the first question
rectangles dimensions they're all two by
four okay so how do I find out where C
is how do I find out what do you reckon
well I've got my diagram here let me get
rid of some of these up I've got so many
lines here let me get rid of some of
them whoops okay look I know what W and
H are right so I could for instance go
this way that's four and in this way
that's two so if I go six units to the
right that should give me the x
coordinate right which is nine what
about the y coordinate I have to go up
from four and I have to go up four units
so that's gonna be a